من بيروت الخبير العسكري واستراتيجيه
العميد المتقاعد الياس حنا العميد حنا اذن
بحسب قياده
العمليات الاوكرانيه الجنوبيه زياده قطع
حربيه روسيه في البحر الاسود الى سبعه من
بينها سفن انزال هل في هذا مؤشر بتقديرك
هي احدى المؤشرات جلال
مؤشرات اخرى ما يجري في بيلاروسيا مؤشرات
اخرى ما يحدث في الادار وحتى ما تموت
مؤشرات اخرى هذا الاستدعاء والتحضير وحتى
العمل بجديه
والضغط على المصانع الانتاج العسكريه
لانتاج المزيد من الاسلحه والذخائر وحتى
الصواريخ هذا الامر همم نوعيه السلاح فيها
كلبر في البحر الاسود هي عمليه انزال كل
هذا يؤجل الى مكان عمليه مستقبليه بمكان
الماء ولكن لسنا بعد في مرحله التنفيذ هي
مرحله التحضير لمرحله ما بعد الشتاء وعن
هذه المرحله خاصه ما يتعلق بسوليدار في
حال اكتملت السيطره تماما لروسيا ماذا بعد
سوليدار العميد
بالعقل الروسي وبالعقيده الروسيه دائما
هناك تقدم على البلدات والتقدم على القرى
وبالتالي محاوله تطويق الهدف الاساسي الا
وهو مخموت سوليدار هي مرحله بسيطه
للانضمام للوصول الى محمود وما يسمى
بالقلدرن يعني ايه هذا الجيش الروسي يطوق
المدينه يقطع عنها خطوط الامدادات من كل
الجهات وبالتالي يجعلها وكانها جهنم من
خلال القصف والتقدم القصف والتقدم هذا ما
حصل بسبريدونالدز شكرا العميدنا في بيروت